more than a year under the pandemic the
virus is once again surging across the
globe
in the past two weeks the number of
deaths worldwide worldwide has risen
12 the virus has claimed more than 3
million lives and daily cases are on the
rise during that time as well up 27
percent
nowhere is that more apparent than in
india where cases have exploded
to more than 300 000 per day
lucy kraft reports on this starting in
march
millions have converged on the ganges
river to cleanse their sins in a bathing
ritual called the world's biggest
religious festival
masks social distancing and other
antiviral measures were in short supply
so instead of salvation india has been
cursed
with the world's fastest rate of covet
infection as pilgrims helped seed
outbreaks across the nation
the terrifying toll was on display this
week with cities forced to hold
makeshift mass cremations
prime minister narendra modi who this
week said india has been slammed by a
coveted storm
has continued to hold mass political
rallies huge soldier
doctor who works at a hospital in
kolkata
said physicians have been shocked to see
the virus attack parents and children
alike
what is uh actually saddening is
the the entire family is being affected
at one point
in time this is what we are seeing these
are the things which
mainly uh you know this gives us also a
sense of anguish and despair
as india's healthcare system collapses
social media has become a chorus of
desperation
young and old rich and poor plead for
oxygen
hospital beds and drugs said independent
journalist
smita sharma i think there's just one
way to describe it right now
it's a living hell it's a nightmare
it's traumatic for all of us we are all
just scarred and i think
very very scared at this point in time
while india's official death toll at
under 200 000
is still only one third that of the u.s
indian funeral workers say the true
number of casualties
is far higher experts warn that even
before this spike abates
a third wave is on the way for cbs this
morning saturday
lucy craft tokyo